day 18 of the ukraine war and to discuss
the latest developments i'm joined by
general sir richard barron's former
commander of joint forces command and
let's start by looking at the west of
ukraine uh because there has been a
strike on a military base in yavariv
which is very close to the polish border
richard why the significance of this
military base so this is an illustration
of the russian military expanding their
campaign further into the west of
ukraine to do two things one is to
inhibit the ukrainian air force's
freedom of action and the other is to
intercept the flow of weapons and other
supplies coming out of the west into
ukraine and then on to where the
fighting is further uh in the east now
that is a military base which is just
six miles from a border with a nato
country how accurate are these russian
missiles particularly if they're coming
from a long way away so we believe in
this case there were 30 missiles fired
over the space of an hour and whether
they came from an aircraft or a ground
launcher if they were cruise missiles
they'd be accurate to between five and
30 meters so there was no real danger of
them hitting nato territory let's look
at the south of ukraine then because we
know there's been continued fighting
around the the besieged city of mariopol
of course on that land corridor between
mother russia uh over uh in the east
and uh crimea which uh russia occupied
in 2014 and we've got some satellite
images that show some of the fighting
these come from max r this is before the
strike on a residential area keep a look
at these buildings down here and then
after the strike you can see the damage
uh on the next image
and richard what is the significance of
of this kind of attack so the
significance of this is a very clear
example of using a lot of fire artillery
against a residential area to damage
buildings and kill the civilian
population create terror that is not an
accident and finally let's look at a map
of of kiev them because we we know that
there's been a continued build-up both
from uh the east uh and the the north
west and also from the west too they are
surrounding the city can they do it with
the forces they have
so we're shaping up for by far the
biggest fight of this war so far kiev is
about 320 square miles the russians
maybe have in total perhaps 60 70 000
soldiers when they attacked berlin in
1945 use one and a half million soldiers
so they're going to have to make some
choices about what they do do they
simply lay siege to the city do they
attack on a narrow access or or do they
do what they've done in other places and
and try and destroy it and then walk in
and of course these supply lines are
getting longer and longer and more
vulnerable to attack from other other
ambush units yes of course ukrainian
military will know that
they can squeeze the russians at all
points between the border and kiev
general sir richard barrons thank you
very much and we will be taking a look
at this through the afternoon as the
russians move further into ukrainian
territory